you've probably heard of machine
learning that's when a computer learns
everything it needs to know from a giant
data set using trial and error but
that's not what babies do they aren't a
clean slate upon entering the world
babies have innate knowledge that helps
them to voraciously learn and rapidly
adapt there are just some things you
can't learn from trial and error but
many computer scientists argue that most
human skills are learned and a I could
learn them too without the need for
pre-loaded rules still a growing number
of researchers are attempting to encode
AI with a bit of common sense the
current craze in AI are neural nets
collections of simple computing elements
loosely modeled on neurons in the brain
that adjust their connections as they
encounter more data they've produced
incredible achievements in the past few
years from facial recognition to beating
humans at poker and go but neural nets
require thousands of training examples
to reliably form associations and even
then they can produce some embarrassing
blunders compare this to a child who can
see an image just once and after that
instantly recognize it in other contexts
some a eyes can play classic Atari games
with superhuman skill but when you
remove all the aliens but one the player
inexplicably becomes a sitting duck
different labs are categorizing human
instincts and then trying to encode them
into AI these systems sit somewhere
between pure machine learning and
completely programmed one team developed
an AI called interaction networks
they've embedded the rule that such a
thing as objects and relationships
between those objects exist this is like
a baby's innate parsing of the world
into objects in tests once the AI learns
the specific properties and
relationships it's able to predict the
behavior of following strings and
bouncing balls in a box another groups
neural physics engine beat less
structured neural nets at predicting
ball collisions and containers
and a lab created an AI which has an
embedded rule to treat letters as
objects and separate them from their
background this allowed it to solve
CAPTCHAs better than other neural nets
that were trained with 50,000 times more
data we're far away from a is that can
truly think like humans but with these
latest attempts to reproduce
common-sense artificially researchers
believe they will get closer to creating
robots that can fully interact with the
world the way we do machines that start
like a baby and learn like a child